Hey youtubers it’s Charlie this is my Korra
episode 4 video.
I’ll say probably one of my favorite episodes
of the entire series so far.
And it had one of the best animation sequences
on the series so far.
So I’ll start with top 5 moments then do
my review.
And new round of the giveaway starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Airbender Mission Impossible
The episode was called the calling, but metaphorically
both the airbender children and Korra couldn’t
hear the message until they dropped their
baggage.
Thematically the two storyline’s didn’t
sync up quite as much as I thought they could,
but you could view the bag of food as a mirror
for Korra’s metal bits in her body.
Both the children and Korra had physical and
emotional baggage weighing them down.
The Swamp vines trying to keep them in the
swamp were also a little like the Swamp trying
to teach Korra a lesson.
The Swamp is a singular organism which is
really the Banyan Grove Tree, so we should
say that the Banyan Tree was trying to teach
everyone the lesson.
Meelo’s line about trying to toughen up
Jinora and Meelo was a good way to explain
the whole arc of the episode.
I was trying to toughen up these ladies but
it was a team effort.
The funny thing about that is it makes it
sound like Meelo is a representation of the
Banyan Grove Tree.
Number 4 - Ikki with the Guards
We were kind of disconnected from what was
going on in the Earth Kingdom so in addition
to just being a funny scene, this also informs
us that Kuvira is marching almost the entire
army on Zhaofu.
I guess that’s going to go down next week.
I loved how Ikki turned into this miyazaki-type
precocious little girl winning over the guards.
I know it seemed like she wasn’t aware they
wanted to capture korra but that bit at the
end where she figured out Korra was in the
swamp made me feel like she knew what was
going on the whole time.
One of the things I like about animation in
general, not just anime, is that the children
are usually smarter than the adults.
South Park is probably the best example but
it seems like the younger you are, the more
wisdom you get to impart.
Like even Korra learns a lot from Jinora who’s
much much younger.
Jinora and Tenzin are probably an even better
comparison.
One of these days I hope they release an Avatar
Map Book.
Like A Song of Ice And Fire has a big really
mind blowing book of maps.
I want one for Last Airbender and Korra that
just shows different maps based on the different
eras of each Avatar.
Or even just a detailed encyclopedia of all
the previous avatars starting with Wan.
Even if it just had their names and a short
sentence about each one.
We really only know a lot about a handful
of them.
But when you look at all the statues in the
air temple you can see there have been thousands
of avatars.
It’s been over ten thousand years since
Wan lived.
Number 3 - Story Time with Toph
This was some serious fan service, I threw
some rocks at the avatar, he whined.
What’s there to tell.
I love that as toph has gotten older, her
personality has regressed back to what it
was like during last airbender.
In the Lin flashbacks during Book 3 the middle-aged
toph looked way more serious and burdened
by all the political aspects of running a
large police force.
It totally makes sense that after she dropped
that ball and chain she’d start loosening
up.
Last Airbender Toph always seemed like the
most chill of all the team aang characters.
She still had her own demons to deal with
but she was kind of a hippie.
She refused to wear shoes and she really didn’t
care about most of the big political or social
things going on in the world.
She was also the most in-tune with nature.
I think Suyin said that she was the one who
originated Zhaofu, so it’s like Toph was
this very balanced person and one child rebelled
by becoming super hardcore, Lin and the other
child, Suyin, rebelled by going extreme in
the other direction.
Super new wave hippie.
It makes me feel like Toph is the wisest person
in the avatar universe right now.
She is the only one who is completely balanced.
Number 2 - Korra at the Banyan Grove Tree
Lots of crying going on for the last 5 minutes
of the episode.
The Bayan Tree animation was very similar
to the way they animated the last airbender
scene with Aang seeing through the root system
to find people.
Very nice callback.
I’m guessing Jinora wasn’t able to sense
her because her spiritual alignment was so
out of whack.
There’s always been something about the
swamp that makes it seem like a spiritual
shield.
Like there’s so much spiritual energy crackling
around, individual people are too hard to
pinpoint.
I also loved Toph’s lesson.
There’s a saying that goes good and bad
luck always come in three’s which is all
I could think about when Korra was having
visions of all three of her former enemies.
That was a badass animation sequence.
The way they super imposed those moments.
I’m wondering if that’s the last time
we’re going to see them.
If Korra got rid of the baggage, then presumably
they’re not rattling around in her head
anymore.
We typically only see things that Korra is
actively thinking about.
I know everyone is wondering if we’ll see
the former avatar lives again.
The comics are kind of a backdoor to that.
Bryke said they didn’t want Korra to have
that crutch to lean on in Book 4.
But there’s still the possibility that she
could reconnect with them after she resolves
the conflict this season.
and my Number 1 moment - Korra Restores her
Avatar State
Does anyone else think that Korra is her own
worst enemy.
Like she has almost unlimited power but because
mentally she’s been unable to process what’s
been going on, she pretty much neutralizes
herself.
She did what all those villains were trying
to do to her.
But she just fixed it so we’re good to go.
We can resume the action.
The last two episodes were really a break
in the main storyline for her.
Just wandering around the swamp with Toph.
Korra’s vacation from being the avatar is
over.
The metalbending scene was probably the most
beautiful animation I’ve seen on Korra ever.
And it’s only episode 4.
So I’m expecting something even better later
this season.
Bryke definitely went all out for these final
episodes.
I can’t wait to listen to the dvd commentary
and hear what they have to say about the more
technical aspects of scenes like this.
They didn’t say anything about it at comic
con just because it would have been super
spoilery.
Let me know what your favorite moment was.
And while you think about that here’s some
awesome news.
They did a Q&A session on the Avatar Wiki
yesterday and said there would be lots more
Last Airbender Comics an Korra stuff from
Dark Horse.
No more tv shows of course, but lots more
comics.
Dark Horse has been their publisher and they’re
very excited to continue making new comic
stories.
So don’t expect new avatars any time soon
but it’s possible after they’ve felt like
they’ve done all the korra stories they
want to do they could introduce a new avatar
in
the comics.
Overall I gave this episode a B plus.
The Korra storyline was amazing but I don’t
feel like the Airbender half of the episode
was as strong.
I just don’t think the Korra baggage was
reflected in the baggage the airbenders were
carrying around.
Ikki had that line about being left out of
the action.
Her siblings never inlcude her.
That would have rang a little stronger if
it had been something closer to what Korra
has been going through.
Other people only ever want to include her
in things, she’s the one who purposefully
stepped away.
Metaphorically all the beats worked for me
in the episode, they were both great stories
the airbenders and Korra, I just feel like
they could have been in sync a little more.
Like if they had just made Jinora the center
of the airbender story and explained why she
was having so much trouble with her spiritual
radar.
So, Q&A tomorrow, be sure to leave all your
questions.
If you haven’t seen my other videos this
week, Constantine is premiering on NBC tonight
so be sure to check it out.
It’s going to be a lot of fun.
It’s one of the new DC Comics tv shows.
It’s based on the Hellblazer comics.
I’ll post my review after the episode airs.
Right now click here for the Korra Q&A and
click here for last week’s episode.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and play some more of the korra game.